the jurogan experience there's something
to that and there's something again from
me a guy who you know for 40 plus years
of my life didn't eat wild game and then
i eat it all the time right it's
different it's different i i get beat up
for this too because
i guess you know vegans can say whatever
they want about hunters and it's good to
go i put up i remember i put up one
thing about a vegan i can't remember
what it was it's like some their diet
and it's like they went from this
healthy person to looking pretty sickly
well there's a lot of those and it's
kind of a meme joke thing and i'm just
like oh no actually god and this is i'm
probably stepping in
i know you can't get canceled but maybe
i can but i put up uh something about
canelo because i guess yeah i guess he
went yeah he went vegan for his last
fight and all i put up was that worked
well yeah i reposted it
i posted in my instagram story i got so
much hate for that yeah you know and
it's like we get crucified for being you
know killers and meat eaters and all
this i put up one joke meme about canelo
who looked
awful compared to how he and with the
one thing that changed was his diet and
then also i'm the bad guy but anyway
well
there's two things going on there one
beval is a real legit light heavyweight
and that's only the second light
heavyweight that canelo had fought the
first one was kovalev but kovalev was at
the end of his career kovalev had lost a
bunch of times he'd been stopped and he
wasn't the same guy as he was like when
he fought andre ward the first time well
kovalev when he was the man when he was
a light heavyweight champion was a real
savage and he was winning that fight
with canelo too by the way there's a
reason why there's weight glasses and
canelo fought floyd mayweather i believe
he fought him at 152 pounds which is the
lightest he's ever fought generally he
would fight at 152 54 and then he moved
up
fought middleweight and that's where he
fought gernard i think he fought triple
g
um gernady golovkin i think he fought
him at 60 or it might have been super
middleweight
find out if that's
so then there's a jump man and the j i
think it was 160 they go up golovkin was
the middleweight champion and so that 15
pound jump is giant but you so you want
to go up and wait and quit eating meat
let's see what it says here
60. yeah okay so that was the they
fought three twice they were supposed to
fight a third time but it looks like
he's going to have a rematch with beval
instead but if you're going to go up
yeah you don't well it's like he he
watched that documentary on netflix game
changers and
there's a lot of
you know look if you want to eat
only vegan and you want to do it for
ethical reasons and you don't want to be
involved in animal death i get it you
don't want to be involved in factory
farming i get it
um but
it's not true when you say that it gives
you a significant athletic performance
boost it doesn't there's no real proof
of that and they [ __ ] with some
reality when they made that they did
there's no real elite professional
athletes at the highest level that i'm
aware of that are vegan i don't i don't
think it has the same bioavailability
as animal protein and this is coming
from nutritionists that aren't are
unbiased and objective not coming from
guys like you know the carnivore md paul
saladino guys who like are proselytizing
to eat carnivorously
this is just from like regular
scientists they'll tell you like you can
get as much protein from x amount of
broccoli right as you can from a steak
the problem is it's not the same kind of
protein it's not as bioavailable and if
okay so if survive surviving is one
thing right thriving performing right or
thriving is a whole nother thing yeah
you can eat a lot of [ __ ] and just get
by
and not die that's the real question but
are you trying to be
optimum performance at whatever you do i
was a vegetarian for six months well i
would tell you that when i was fighting
because i was having a really hard time
making weight and uh i wound i was i was
you know
i was uh competing when i was 17. i won
the state championship at 140 pounds and
the next weight class was 154
and i was struggling at one i couldn't
really get i wasn't 140. i was like 153
154 and i would dehydrate the [ __ ] out
of myself
make the weight and then i have to fight
on the same day it was not good and i
was fighting
i didn't i won but i felt like [ __ ] i
was like i could have [ __ ] those guys
up if i was yeah like if i felt my best
strong right and then i did it for a
while to try to lean out but i was just
tired all the time and i know i probably
wasn't doing it right and i've never
done it right where you know you eat pea
protein and you make sure you balance
your macros and have someone
but when i when i started eating meat
that's when i became at my best when i
went on my my best performance run as a
competitor it was all eating meat and
that's mostly what i ate was meat right
and i felt a lot different and that was
the only example that i've ever had
because it's a straight only stretch of
my life when i was competing
a very intense thing and i did eat i ate
nothing but vegetables for like a good
six months that's a long time it was a
long time i tried as long because i had
my instructor was very tall and we were
from the same weight class you know am i
140 might have been 147 whatever it was
i forgot what the weight class was but
it was in the 40s and then he was like
6-3 6-2-6-3 and he was in the same way
class as me when he was younger was
competing so i was like brainwashed to
think like i'm too short for this
[ __ ] weight class so i gotta start
myself yeah but it's just body types and
then did you see oozman at the last
fight with his red leather jacket no
shirt
baller
[Laughter]
well he's like you know that if you want
to make something make some noise and
get some attention that's how you do it
well he's trying to get that canelo
fight i know he wants that big big money
and maybe canal will fight him let's
keep him on salad i'll fight
keep him on salads he's got a pretty
good shot
keep him on salads yeah i wonder if
he'll change his diet because they were
actually talking about that in the
broadcast they were saying he seems a
little lackadaisical
a little lackluster i wonder if it's his
diet
i don't know yeah after the fight
talking about the diet it's like
i don't know you know i know it's like i
never want to say that it won't work for
you because there's people out there
that i know that are vegan that thrive
and they don't have any problem with it
but i don't know how they would do if
they meet i mean maybe they're just
[ __ ] unbelievably savage and if they
meet they'd be even better but if you
give them vegetables they'll still kill
it his quote on it says that
sometimes he eats meat still oh i'm not
very complicated when it comes to food i
adapt a lot i adapt quickly canelo told
espn it's it's not something i did all
of a sudden that i left what i ate
before from one day to the next all week
i try to eat what is vegan and if one
day i eat something else meat chicken
whatever i eat it there's no problem
yeah i don't know what that means really
but that's what he said in response but
that's not if you are um an athlete that
is eating for performance like say if
you went to uh
that's the opposite of me yeah if you
went to a mike dolce or uh you know
george lockhart or one of those guys
that is not how they would tell you to
eat they would prescribe a specific
amount of protein yeah specific amount
of carbohydrates based on your weight
right i mean they're not saying like
sometimes i eat this and sometimes eat
that
i think what's going on is canelo is so
[ __ ] good yeah that he can get away
with eating squash and tomatoes yeah and
still [ __ ] you up because he's so
goddamn good he's been amazing he's
amazing and just the fact that he went
all the way up to 75 fought beval
went to the decision you know lost the
lost the decision but was never in like
real trouble yeah was never like rocked
or dropped or anything like that and
he's fighting two weight classes above
his natural weight class it's kind of
crazy yeah it is he's he's an amazing
fighter he's amazing he's one of the
greatest of all time which is why he's
willing to take that chance and go up to
175 pounds
but
in my mind if you're a athlete
especially if you're in a combat sport
you need to have everything dialed up
dialed in your recovery you need to be
doing a sauna every day ice bath you
need to be eating all the right food
drinking all the white water they should
hydration test you every day you got
hundreds of millions of dollars on the
line that's canelo alvarez i know he
shouldn't be eating [ __ ] plants
[ __ ] are you doing bro you eating celery
we gotta get a steak in you yeah well
that's what i was saying is like his
approach where he'll eat you know greens
and salads most time and every once in a
while have meat i do
all meat and every once in a while have
a salad you know when mike tyson was in
here he was thanking me for turning him
onto wild games really yes he's been
getting wild game yes from i i offered
to get him some elk but i never got it
to him we never connected after that but
he went to uh somewhere and got a lot of
bison he got uh he was eating a lot of
bison yeah before uh he started training
again he's like oh my god it made such a
difference he thanked me during the last
podcast we're turning on because i'm
always talking about wild game yeah and
he's like it made a big difference
that's what i eat now is wild game so if
mike tyson says that
i'd [ __ ] listen